je suis vraiment très très heureuse de
vous accueillir ici alors la salle est
un peu impressionnante je disais madame
la Présidente d'alga c'est un lieu
d'inspiration aujourd'hui carrément
peut-être un lieu de méditation parce
que les rideaux ont été baissés mais ça
n'est pas un lieu de confession voilà je
vous je vous rassure en tout cas
elles ne sont pas interdites
voilà je sais que vous avez un grand
cœur vraiment merci merci beaucoup vous
savez notre délégation au collectivités
et à la décentralisation est au cœur de
la mission du Sénat et puis
l'écoute la rencontre avec les
associations des lieux est essentielles
pour nourrir notre notre réflexion et
puis pratiquer ce que nous appelons ici
le bottom up plutôt que le Top Down
alors on sent que ici un peu parfois
mais il nous semble et depuis
enfin je veux dire des travaux que nous
menons aujourd'hui
à la fois la délégation mais sur
d'autres missions on voit combien
il est important de partir des réalités
de la diversité de nos territoires pour
construire
l'organisation et la définition
de l'action publique plutôt que de
d'avoir de ces définitions un peu
théoriques dans lesquelles on s'évertit
à faire entrer la vie de nos concitoyens
et des élus qui ne rentrent jamais dans
des modèles un peu trop carrés alors le
plaisir que nous avons aujourd'hui c'est
de parler avec vous de l'actualité
naturellement des régions alors
j'évoquerai quelques sujets que nous
partageons ensemble le zéro
artificialisation
nette qui est
aujourd'hui la préoccupation majeure de
tous les élus et dont tous nos
territoires vous savez que à la suite de
la parution des décrets d'applications
de la loi résilience beaucoup d'émotions
est apparue à la fois chez les élus ici
au Sénat parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
que il y avait une vraie difficulté à
transformer un objectif
de zéro artificialisation n'est que
personne ne conteste au sens où la
frugalité ou la sobriété foncière est
déjà souvent pratiquée qu'il convient de
le faire est quand même temps
ces décrets d'application contenaient
des injonctions contradictoires et il
nous paraît un peu difficile de devoir
concilier la réindustrialisation dans
notre pays l'aménagement
d'infrastructures l'accueil de
population et que nous nous sentions et
c'était fortement exprimé les collègues
le diront une nouvelle fracture
territoriale un peu épidermique qui
apparaissait
des régions rurales considérant que le
zan tel que le décret d'application le
décrivait pouvait être en quelque sorte
une extinction des lumières
dans la ruralité donc le Sénat
organisé une mission spéciale conduit
par Valérie l'Etat et Jean-Baptiste
blanc pour entendre écouter réfléchir et
cette mission aboutit une proposition de
loi qui va être discuter très
prochainement au Sénat à la Mima et nous
savons que dans ce zéro
artificialisation
le rôle des régions est un rôle éminent
parfois plus ou moins comment dire
qui suscite semble-t-il dans certaines
régions
peu d'appétence en disant qu'il ne
s'agit pas pour nous les régions d'être
amenés
à être l'autorité qui va apparaître
comme celle qui rationne kiabitres voilà
donc c'est un vrai sujet pour nous et
aussi pour vous c'en est certainement un
puisqu'il y a cette notions d'équilibre
territorial dans chacune des régions le
deuxième sujet celui des mobilités
aujourd'hui il y a un enjeu majeur en
termes de mobilité on le sait moi je
suis très sensible
à aux déclarations de régions de France
qui enfin les régions sont des acteurs
majeurs de la mobilité et que cela bien
été défini dans la loi mobilité qui
était porté à l'époque où armadamboard
mais qui comme bien souvent dans notre
pays parce que c'est ainsi que les
choses se font on parle philosophie
alors on trouve les idées assez géniales
et dans un deuxième temps on parle
argent et là ça devient un petit peu
plus compliqué et on voit bien qu'il y a
un véritable une véritable question pour
les régions sur le financement de votre
compétence mobilité à force y aurait
avec le New Deal ferroviaire qui est
annoncé qui est en soit une bonne chose
donc je pense que vous nous en parlerez
certainement et puis troisième point et
j'en terminerai
là pour les questions un peu technique
c'est la situation financière des
régions c'est à dire comment est-ce que
on voit aujourd'hui l'évolution de cette
situation financière sachant que vous
êtes aussi particulièrement impacté par
la hausse du coût de l'énergie car je
crois que c'est un milliard 15
de surcoût de coûts supplémentaires dont
30% dans les lycées et les transports et
puis une question alors non pas
philosophique mais c'est une question
qui va nous permettre de nous élever
n'est-ce pas qui à laquelle vous avez
beaucoup participé
dans la réflexion qu'avec conduit le
président l'archet en 2020 réflexion qui
avait amené au 50 propositions en faveur
des libertés locales puisque au centre
territoire Unis vous aviez été très
actif dans dans le travail que nous
avions conduit aujourd'hui le président
du Sénat à nouveau relancé la réflexion
avec un on peut transpartisan et nous
pensons que
il faut vraiment que nous t'ayons la
leçon de la crise de la covid qui a
vraiment permis de découvrir à ceux qui
l'ignoraient l'important et la capacité
des collectivités à gérer un certain
nombre de compétences avec beaucoup
d'agilité de réactivité et dans un mode
que j'appelle les circuits courts qui
sont très tendance en ce moment au salon
de l'agriculture de manière générale
mais qui dans notre pays dans notre
culture
on va dire de l'action publique sont
encore un peu des choses oubliées que on
cultive alors peut-être que c'est malgré
nous je ne sais pas et quand je dis on
a assez général c'est de
recentralisation donc peut-être par leur
aurons-nous de ça les perspectives de
décentralisation et si l'on peut parler
aussi un peu de votre vision du
conseiller territor IAL qui semble
ressusciter voilà merci beaucoup madame
à présent merci à vous donc nous
disposons d'envir une heure un peu plus
et je suis sûr que mes collègues que je
salue auront également beaucoup de
questions merci
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous remercier pour cette
audition sur les sujets que vous avez
abordés madame la Présidente mais de
façon on va dire plus générique sur la
situation de la France et quels sont les
solutions que nous pouvons apporter à
travers une réforme institutionnelle
annoncée par Monsieur le Président de la
République à travers le travail mené par
le Sénat comme vous l'avez rappelé que
ça soit sur les 50 propositions qui
avaient été menées en lien avec
territoires unis ou également sur toutes
les initiatives qui sont menées en
termes de proposition de loi pour le
zéro artificialisation nette ou
également le rapport du Sénat sur
l'addiction aux normes
voulions en fait l'ensemble des
présidentes des présidents de région de
France vous faire partager
notre notre vision la réalité de ce que
nous vivons et également les ambitions
que nous avons pour le pays nous sommes
dans un temps de crise et donc nous
pensons que dans ce temps de crise il
est nécessaire d'avoir de la clarté et
de l'audace alors il faut quand on est
en responsabilité politique avoir
toujours de l'optimisme et revenir au
sens étymologique du terme crise et nous
savons que la crise donc au niveau de la
civilisation grecque était un moment de
transition et qui permettait d'avoir une
transformation du modèle et nous avons
une crise
d'une journée au débute le débat sur les
retraites une crise sociale sur cette
réforme des retraites une crise
climatique
mobilisation à l'échelle de la planète
contre lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique bien entendu crise de
l'énergie avec les conséquences sur une
inflation qui est forte pour nous
concitoyens pour nos entreprises
également et risque de perte majeures de
compétitivité pour nos entreprises en
particulier sur les questions de
production et puis aussi une crise de
confiance dans dans l'action publique
qui se traduit par bien sûr l'abstention
mais également par les votes populistes
que nous combattons bien entendu tous
attachés à la République pour notre pays
cette crise bien sûr de la confiance
dans l'action publique c'est parce que
nous concitoyens le sentiment de ne pas
être entendu on le sentiment que la
politique
ne peut pas changer le cours du destin
du destin au titre collectif au titre
aussi
individuel et je lisais ces derniers
jours les propos de docteur anciences
politiques madame kg qui était très très
intéressant c'est propos et qui en fait
mettaient en avant le sentiment de
classe enfermé plutôt que la dichotomie
que nous connaissons de classe moyenne
ainsi de suite ce sentiment d'être dans
une classe enfermée dans une classe
empêchée et je trouve que cela fait
particulièrement écho à vos propos
introductifs madame la Présidente parce
que nous avons besoin de donner de la
liberté à nos concitoyens et de la
liberté aux collectivités locales et la
question de l'enfermement elle est bien
sûr liée ce n'est pas notre sujet
de coeur aujourd'hui mais elle est liée
bien sûr à la problématique de
l'éducation nationale reviendront dans
les propositions que les présidentes et
les présidents de région de France nous
faisons sur la question de l'orientation
scolaire et également sur la question de
la formation la question du sentiment
d'enfermement elle est liée aux mobilité
mobilité physique après les mobilités de
l'esprit et puis la question bien sûr du
du rapport au travail et la question
aussi de l'aménagement du territoire et
de ne pas être dans des territoires
figés mais dans des territoires qui
puissent
évoluer donc nous souhaitons vraiment
avoir de la clarté et donc nous avons
demandé un rendez-vous à monsieur le
Président de la République au niveau de
territoires Unis ce sera le 13 mars
l'ensemble des associations des élus
vont être reçues le 13 mars et nous
demande monsieur le Président de la
République qui nous explique que les
objectifs
qui fixe à cette réforme
institutionnelle et d'avoir à partir des
objectifs partagés une méthode avoir de
la clarté mais aussi avoir de l'audace
l'audace d'aller dans une vraie
décentralisation dans dans ce pays avec
la question des libertés locales le
Sénat il travaille voilà de façon forte
et depuis longtemps parce qu'à travers
la démocratie de proximité à travers un
pouvoir de décision plus proche de nos
concitoyens on renoue le lien de
confiance et surtout on apporte des
vraies solutions aux problèmes de nos
concitoyens il faut avoir le courage ou
l'audace de renoncer à la l'inflation
des normes comme vous l'avez appelé à
vos vœux parce que outre la complexité
ça a un coût tout budgétaire et que vous
avez évalué à 2 milliards euros sur le
coup de normes supplémentaires sur les
cinq dernières années et puis également
avoir de l'audace sur la question de la
différenciation territoriale et j'ai pu
m'entretenir le mois dernier avec
monsieur le Président Larcher et que
nous puissions aller dans une
différenciation dans la différenciation
et je pense tout particulièrement au
territoire d'outre-mer ou à la Corse
puisque
l'ensemble des présidents des présidents
de région sont favorables à une
autonomie renforcée pour la Corse mais
également à ce qu'ils puissent y avoir
une différenciation dans la
différenciation pour nos territoires
d'outre-mer parce que les sujets de la
Réunion sont différents de ceux par
exemple des Antilles et nous devons
avoir cette capacité à agir parce que
nous en avons la maturité politique et
nous avons aussi un état de droit qui
garantit bien sûr
que les principes de notre République
soit appliquée sur l'ensemble de nos de
nos territoires alors les les régions
nous sommes
des acteurs qui avant à travers leur
nouveau le permis périmètre et à travers
les nouvelles compétences
un acteur qui est encore plus présent
dans le quotidien des Français nous
l'avons démontré au moment de la crise
sanitaire nous sommes unis pour pouvoir
acheter massivement des masques
organiser des centres de vaccination
avec les communes et surtout nous avons
augmenté fortement notre investissement
entre 2019 et donc 2021 nous avons
augmenté notre investissement de plus de
20% parce que nous avons été
accompagnants et également stimulant
pour les de relance qui avait été lancé
sous l'égide de l'ancien premier
ministre Jean Castex donc des régions
qui sont engagées qui n'ont pas retrouvé
leur niveau de l'autofinancement avant
crise parce que il a été nécessaire
d'augmenter fortement les aides aux
entreprises à toutes les entreprises que
ça soit un des
commerçants des artisans mais également
aider pour l'innovation et la recherche
pour les grandes entreprises parce que
nous partageons l'absolument l'absolu
nécessité que nous puissions avoir une
souveraineté dans notre pays
souveraineté bien sûr industrielle qui
passe par des investissements forts au
niveau de l'innovation mais également un
accompagnement sur l'ensemble des
territoires souveraineté alimentaire
semaine sur du Salon de l'Agriculture
souveraineté sanitaire et souveraineté
aussi
énergétique il y a des rumeurs comme
quoi il y aurait des réflexions sur le
redécoupage des régions alors de quatre
grandes régions grands tests donc
nouvelle Aquitaine Auvergne Rhône-Alpes
et donc l'Occitanie donc j'ai répondu en
tant que présidente de région de France
nous n'avons pas souhaité les autres
présidents rentrés dans une polémique à
partir de rumeurs ou de propos d'un
président d'un parti politique parce que
nous pensons que avant de parler de
redécoupage faisons le bilan et des
Lindsay en a fait des une première
évaluation et à démontrer que dans ces
grandes régions la dynamique économique
était beaucoup plus
renforcer et c'est pour cela qu'en plus
à titre personnel j'ai toujours défendu
les grandes régions quand j'étais même
vice-présidente de la Région
Midi-Pyrénées parce que avec les grandes
régions c'est la bonne taille pour
pouvoir créer de vraies filières
économiques et si on prend la question
de l'hydrogène sur les énergies
renouvelables cela a été possible de
pouvoir mettre la Supply chaîne dans
l'ensemble de l'hydrogène parce que nous
avons les tailles qui nous permettent de
commencer sur la production sur la
distribution et ensuite sur les les
usages donc des régions qui ont une
situation
financière qui est
solide parce que nous n'avons pas niveau
d'endettement trop élevé nous l'avons
maîtrisé
bien sûr un investissement qui a été
accru comme je voulais indiquer mais
des Finances qui sont soumises là à la
question énergétique de vraiment de
façon forte puisque nous avons comme les
communes comme les départements la
question des dépenses énergétiques dans
nos bâtiments mais en plus nous avons la
question des dépenses énergétiques sur
les questions des transports
transports scolaires donc avec aussi le
prix des carburants mais également dans
notre partenariat avec la SNCF donc là
nous négocions sur ces conventions qui
sont assez techniques pour que la SNCF
nous facturent pas au-delà du coût réel
de ce qu'ils ont pu
subir et de plus cette problématique
budgétaire très significative sur
l'augmentation des factures énergétiques
de la SNCF est aggra par un coût des
péages qui pourrait être augmenté de
l'ordre de 8%. alors donc je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail du financement
des réseaux ferroviaires en France mais
c'est quand même un non sens parce que
plus vous faites rouler de tringle et
plus votre coude des péages augmentent
donc si nous n'étions pas des présidents
responsables la solution budgétaire
serait qu'il y ait le moins de train
possible et nos finances s'emporteraient
le mieux possible mais seulement nous
territoire nous les aimons et surtout
nous les vivons et nous savons à quel
point il est indispensable d'avoir le
rail d'avoir des trames des tringles
d'aménagement du territoire et puis des
tringles aussi
grande vitesse pour finir le maillage
des LGV donc ce que nous souhaitons nous
les régions c'est d'avoir une vision des
objectifs qui qui soit clair et des
réponses qui soient apportées à ce que
nous considérons
comme des difficultés pour notre pays
donc le premier sujet la question de
l'écart de l'école au sens générique du
terme ce n'est pas juste école primaire
c'est nous pensons que nous devons
redonner la pleine ambition donc à
l'école à la méritocratie républicaine
et nous les régions nous souhaitons que
au niveau de l'orientation scolaire il y
ait une vraie délégation aux régions
puisque il y a une loi qui existe mais
dans les faits il y a des freins qui
sont très très significatifs et nous
souhaitons que cette question de
l'orientation scolaire tout
particulièrement au collège parce que
c'est là que l'orientation scolaire se
joue avant même le lycée et puisse y
avoir de la part des rejoins des régions
qui sont le Goby twin entre le monde de
éducation et le monde de l'entreprise
vraiment une implication plus forte des
salariés des chefs d'entreprise pour
venir témoigner soit dans les écoles
soit dans des salons que nous organisons
à proximité c'est une question de lutte
contre le déterminisme social c'est
aussi une question
de compétitivité de nos entreprises pour
qu'ils puissent y avoir des salariés qui
soient formés qui soient épanouis dans
leur métier et aujourd'hui quand on
rencontre des chefs d'entreprise le
premier sujet est certes l'énergie mais
celui qui vient quasiment au même niveau
c'est la question des difficultés de
recrutement et donc là nous devons
prendre le problème à la base et nous
avons une orientation scolaire qui est
déficiente et nous avons trop de jeunes
qui ne connaissent pas la diversité la
réalité des métiers et qui parfois vont
dans des voies qui ne leur conviennent
pas et quand vous êtes un échec scolaire
pendant plusieurs années cela après a
des en tant que citoyen et également en
tant que que salarié nous demandons
également une réflexion sur la question
de la formation aujourd'hui les régions
nous avons les missions de formation
initiale que ce soit à travers les
lycées que ça soit à travers
l'enseignement supérieur la formation
des demandeurs d'emploi et
la formation des salariés étant
organisée par les OPCO cette division de
la formation ne nous paraît plus
pertinente parce que à la suite de cette
crise sanitaire du confinement il y a
deux tendances structurelles de fond
tout d'abord que nos salariés souhaitent
avoir plusieurs métiers dans une vie
et donc le fait de rester dans une même
entreprise et d'évoluer cela ne
correspond plus avec des métiers très
différents donc c'est pour cas cela que
la question de la de la césure entre la
formation continue et la formation
initiale n'est plus pertinente parce que
souvent des salariés d'un des grandes
entreprises qui ont des moyens
financiers des formations veulent avoir
des formations tout à fait différentes
des métiers de l'entreprise pour aller
vers d'autres horizons et on a le cas
souvent de l'ingénieur qui veut devenir
agriculteur ou commerçant
ou d'un des plus petits entreprises à ce
moment-là des salariés qui vont négocier
une rupture conventionnelle pour pouvoir
après passer par la case de demandeurs
d'emploi pour pouvoir financer une
formation donc on doit prendre en compte
cette relation au travail parce que nous
pensons je le précise dans ces temps
troublé que pour nous le travail est
source d'émancipation
de nous partageons que
il est nécessaire de prendre en compte
ce rapport au travail qui est différent
et d'avoir la volonté d'avoir plusieurs
métiers dans une vie et nous demandons
en effet que l'information des salariés
les régions puisse également
intervenir deuxième tendance
structurelle c'est la nécessité de
retrouver la souveraineté et pour
retrouver de la souveraineté
souveraineté industrielle souveraineté
énergétique nous devons de nouveau avoir
de nouveaux métiers que nous avions il y
a de 150 ans dans ce pays mais que nous
n'avons plus parce qu'il n'y a plus là
il y a eu des industrialisations nous
avons perdu des savoir-faire donc nous
avons besoin de réactualiser ou
carrément de réintroduire de nouveaux
métiers dans notre pays et nous avons
aussi par rapport à la souveraineté
énergétique tous les métiers divers qui
sont liés à la transition écologique et
énergétique que nous devons mettre en
œuvre donc le premier sujet de nos
concitoyens c'est la question de ce
sentiment d'enfermement que le que
l'école ne joue plus son rôle j'aime pas
trop le terme ascenseur social je
préfère escalier de la réussite parce
que dans la vie on n'a plus jamais sur
un bouton pour que chose se passe il
faut toujours faire un effort et dans un
escalier il y a une rampe qui est de
cagnards et le deuxième sujet c'est bien
sur la question de la santé
c'est la difficulté d'accès aux soins et
là nous souhaitons que les régions aient
plus de missions sur la détermination
des places dans les formations
sanitaires et sociales et que nous ne
dépendions pas du gouvernement pour
définir le nombre des places alors qu'il
y a des besoins majeurs sur l'ensemble
de de ces métiers et que nous puissions
avoir dans le cadre de l'expérimentation
la possibilité pour les présidents et
les présidents qui le souhaitent
d'investir dans les hôpitaux
locaux le troisième sujet c'est la
question des mobilités vous en avez
parlé madame la Présidente nous pensons
que il est absolument nécessaire de
développer le rail pour trois raisons
tout d'abord pour les questions de
transition écologique énergétique le
rail et la bonne solution elle n'est pas
l'unique mais la bonne solution au
niveau environnemental sur la question
du pouvoir sur la question de la
souveraineté
industrielle il est absolument
nécessaire et donc nous avons appelé
dans une tribune alors Franck c'était 22
octobre voilà parce que toi tu la
mémoire des dates mieux que moi donc du
22 octobre donc New Deal ferroviaire
nous avions demandé donc 100 milliards
sur les 10 prochaines années ça
correspond pas tout à fait à la nouvelle
donne annoncée par la première ministre
même si nous avons salué l'intention
favorable puisque là c'est 100 milliards
sur les 17 prochaines mais donc nous
allons travailler pour faire monter ce
sujet donc un investissement massif
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'investissement
la moitié des lignes ferroviaires dans
ce pays d'ici 5 ans fermeront c'est une
réalité nous avons un réseau qui est un
très mauvais état donc
nous avons la nécessité de régénérer sur
le terme technique le réseau ferré nous
avons besoin de le moderniser et tout
particulièrement avec les équipements de
RTS de niveau 2 c'est la signalisation
j'étais la semaine dernière au Sénégal
et voilà j'ai pu visiter le nouveau RER
de Dakar et donc là équipé de niveau 2
et donc là à ce moment-là quand on parle
de RER comme l'a fait le monsieur le
Président de la République c'est la
condition essentielle pour avoir en cas
d'encement au quart d'heure parce que si
nous n'avons pas ce système de
signalisation il n'y aura pas le
cadencement au quart d'heure sur un
réseau ferré qui a une lourdeur
technique qui est quand même assez
différente des du RER qu'on peut
connaître ici en région parisienne nous
avons donc besoin de régénération de
modernisation également de financement
des grands projets les grands projets
que ce soit Lyon Turin que ce soit le
canal c'est le nord ou les LGV donc
Marseille Nice donc Toulouse Bordeaux
Dax et Montpellier Perpignan et c'est
pourquoi nous avons estimé que si on
était sur les 17 prochaines années c'est
à l'auteur de 170 milliards qui serait
nécessaire de monter et nous avons outre
développer cette effort budgétaire avec
plusieurs sources bien sûr un engagement
du gouvernement français plus fort je
rappelle que la moyenne par habitant en
France de 44 euros par habitant nous
sommes à 124 euros par habitant en
Allemagne donc nous avons quand même un
déficit d'investissement significatif
depuis longtemps il faut être là aussi
très objectif donc un effort budgétaire
de la part de l'État nous appelons aussi
que ce plan d'investissement ce nous dit
ferroviaire soit porté à l'échelle
européenne avec des crédits européens
qu'il y ait également de nouveaux
systèmes de financement inspirés de la
Société du Grand Paris ou des sociétés
de financement LGV que nous avons pu
créer et également la fin des
concessions autoroutières puisque à
partir de 2028 avec un pic en 2031 nous
aurons la fin des des concessions
autoroutières donc un effort budgétaire
significatif mais qui doit être
également corrélée avec la structuration
d'une filière industrielle à l'échelle
de l'Europe c'est ce que nous avons
appelé l'Airbus ferroviaire et c'est un
projet que j'ai indiqué au président de
la République j'ai suggéré qu'il soit
porté par le couple franco-allemand
Airbus avait été fait dans les dans les
années
60-70 parce que nous avons encore une un
temps d'avance on échelle internationale
sur les savoir-faire ferroviaires nous
devons avoir un géant industriel
européen puisque aujourd'hui en Chine
nous avons ce géant industriel qui est
constitué qui s'appelle
CRC qui est en train de gagner de
nombreux marchés dans le monde et en
particulier aux États-Unis et nous avons
marché mondial du ferroviaire ou
l'industrie française européenne
pourrait prendre toute sa part mais nous
devons avoir une taille optimale voilà
je ne reviendrai pas sur
la fusion avortée de siemensa Alstom
mon ami Alain Châtillon donc avait
travaillé sur sur ce sujet mais nous
devons remettre ce sujet au cœur de
notre réflexion à travers bien sûr
Siemens Alstom mais également le groupe
CAF qui est un groupe espagnol pour
avoir une taille pertinente et pour
pouvoir gagner ces marchés parce que la
position de la Commission européenne est
incompréhensible elle limite la vision
du marché ferroviaire à l'Europe alors
que le potentiel de développement sur le
marché ferroviaire il est mondial et
tout particulièrement je me dis que je
rentre d'Afrique là on voit les besoins
qui sont immenses et y compris en
Amérique du Sud et y compris aux
États-Unis puisqu'il y a certaines États
qui sont très volontaristes sur sur ces
sujets là et cela permettra en ayant un
Airbus ferroviaire d'avoir aussi une
possibilité de reconversion pour nos
salariés de l'industrie automobile qui
vont être frappé de plein fouet par la
fin de la motorisation des ailes alors
quand je dis nos salariés salariés
français mais salarié allemand encore
plus impactés que nous sur sur ces
sujets et nous avons donc cette ambition
parce que qu'on veut parler d'un RER
métropolitain il faut être conscient que
dans de nombreuses métropoles cela n'est
possible que si la création d'une
deuxième voix et donc souvent c'est
corrélé avec la question des
LGV donc là nous devons y travailler et
nous rappeler madame la Présidente nous
avions porté le projet d'agence des
mobilités parce que à part Paris et Lyon
qui est donc qui ont une organisation
spécifique pour les transports les
autres métropoles françaises ont
différents acteurs on va dire une
multiplicité d'acteurs qui interviennent
sur la question des mobilités bien sûr
la métropole bien sûr la région souvent
l'État avec les routes nationales
un propre ou concéder avec les
autoroutes et donc là nous avons parfois
les départements avec les voies
cyclables et là nous avons donc une
multiplicité d'acteurs ou pour organiser
l'intermodalité ça devient quand même
compliqué et c'est pourquoi il est
nécessaire d'avoir une structure qui
puisse piloter cette complémentarité là
alors différentes d'âge de France
mobilité parce qu'il est pas question
d'aller discuter de l'implantation de
l'arrêt de bus mais c'est la question de
la programmation de la complémentarité
des infrastructures routières
ferroviaire et dans nos métropoles nous
devons nous inspirer de ce qui se fait à
Madrid ou aussi aux États-Unis avec des
voies réservées sur les axes entrants
dans les métropoles que ce soit des
routes nationales ou des routes
concédées avec les voies réservées pour
le covoiturage et pour l'écart dont nous
avons la compétence les régions qui font
des moyennes et des longues distances
c'est absolument indispensable pour
favoriser le transport collectif
routier nous avons donc les ces missions
que nous semblent à améliorer sur la
question de l'éducation de la santé de
la mobilité
on se rappelle tout et tous que ce sont
les questions des mobilités qui ont
poussé au mouvement des gilets jaunes et
puis vous l'avez indiqué sur la capacité
des territoires à évoluer à se
transformer et le zéro artificialisation
nette ne doit pas geler des situations
doit au contraire permettre de stopper
l'hypermétropolisation et de permettre
un développement à des territoires qui
sur les 20 dernières années ne l'ont pas
connu mais ces territoires connaissent
en revanche un gain
regain d'attractivité de par les
tendances sociétales qui ont évolué
parce qu'à travers le confinement chacun
et chacune a repris goût à avoir une vie
un territoire rural dans des petites
villes ou dans des villages d'équilibre
et cela il faut arriver à tenir cet
objectif
d'artifilisation artificialisée moins de
terre pour avoir une souveraineté
alimentaire c'est absolument
indispensable mais qu'il y ait un effort
qui soit fait de façon plus grande dans
des territoires qui ont beaucoup
consommé et au contraire de pouvoir
permettre un développement dans des
territoires qui eux n'ont pas vu ou même
parfois on perdus des habitants ces
dernières années c'est ce travail que
nous devons mener c'est pourquoi
région de France Association des Maires
de France nous avons signé ensemble donc
un courrier gouvernement et nous avons
demandé donc qu'il y ait des
caractères moins impératif que ce que le
décret avait prévu et puis également que
les grands projets pardon de
souveraineté
ne soit pas impactée régionalement
projet liés aux infrastructures de
transport projets liés aux
infrastructures économiques parce que si
nous voulons
avoir
le retour d'une souveraineté par nous
vont permettre à nos entreprises de
pouvoir aussi mener
des projets donc nous sommes dans cette
dans cette esprit là que nous avons
souhaité
je pense que j'ai à peu près indiqué des
pistes de réponse
à l'ensemble des
de
vos remarques mais voilà maintenant nous
nous tenons François Bonnot Franck Leroy
et moi-même à votre disposition pour
répondre à l'ensemble des questions si
madame la Présidente j'ai envie que les
collègues qui souhaitent
interpeller madame la Présidente et
président a manifesté merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente d'abord pour cette
vision qui est la vôtre au-delà des
sujets techniques qui relèvent des
compétences des collectivités la
question qui est sous tendue derrière et
qui est essentiel c'est quelle vision
pour notre pays quelle stratégie on met
en œuvre
et pour l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et
vous vous avez tenu un propos très juste
c'est à dire
la crise
parfois est vécue comme un élément que
nous subissons est difficile alors
qu'aujourd'hui je pense que nous sommes
un peu comme sur la transformation d'un
papillon nous sommes en pleine période
de mutation et de transformation et que
je crois qu'il y a aussi un regard
positif à avoir sur les choses sa
nouvelle avenir qu'il faut construire
qui sera très différent de ce que nous
connaissons mais quand même temps qui
empruntent vous l'avez dit notamment en
termes de réindustrialisation qui
empruntent parfois à une histoire à une
histoire récente donc merci vraiment
pour poser le vrai sujet vous l'avez dit
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut de la
clarté de l'audace et cette vision
comment on serait organise quelles
compétences mais pourquoi faire et pour
qui et moi j'aime beaucoup ce que vous
décrivez comme une société qui est un
peu empêchée qui est bloqué c'est ce que
ce qui m'arrive d'appeler de la
signation à résidence c'est-à-dire que
là où vous habitez là parfois vous êtes
condamné à vivre et que il est compliqué
pour un étudiant de la Creuse d'aller
dans une école de commerce universitaire
en Normandie parce que ça n'est pas son
univers il est vraiment empêché donc les
régions jouent un rôle
je lui dis que beaucoup de convictions
absolument stratégiques dans la capacité
à sortir chacun de de son espace vous
avez parlé des mobilités la mobilité est
un enjeu majeur à la fois pour les
entreprises et je ne peux pas m'empêcher
madame la Présidente on vous entendons
de repenser aux déclarations de la
direction de l'entreprise le grand
qui explique que aujourd'hui il est
absolument impossible pour elle où il
peut être impossible de manière des
centres de décision et on connaît
l'importance pour un territoire d'avoir
des centres de décision si nous n'avons
pas enfin ce qu'on appelle le
puddingment une modernisation
une modernisation du du ferroviaire je
pense qu'en matière de mobilité votre
votre proposition d'agence des mobilités
les indispensable parce qu'aujourd'hui
là encore on voit des opérateurs qui
peuvent être des intercommunalités qui
agissent sur leur périmètre
administratifs alors que la mobilité
répond à des exigences de bassin de vie
la mise en place des et des Fe
va aussi aggraver aggraver les choses et
qu'il faut effectivement qu'il y a une
coordination entre les régions les
départements les interco c'est je crois
un enjeu un enjeu majeur pour débloquer
pour débloquer notre pays dernier point
que je voudrais évoquer et monsieur le
Président Bono avait invité quelques-uns
d'entre nous il y a très peu de temps
pour parler des interrogations qui se
posent sur les questions de l'Emploi et
de la Formation et vous savez comment
c'est là nous on a soutenu au moins une
fonction de coordination des régions sur
l'emploi et la formation parce qu'il y a
un lien entre la stratégie et la
compétence économique et la vôtre et qui
exercent de manière très forte et puis
l'emploi pour coordonner tout ça il faut
vraiment qu'on soit en clarté et en
cohérence d'action donc nous nous sommes
très attentifs à cela au Sénat et vous
savez que
le Sénat soutenu ses propositions comme
nous sommes aussi très sensibles à la
formation tout au long de la vie parce
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien la mobilité
professionnelle l'envie d'avoir
plusieurs métiers dans sa vie et cela ne
peut se faire que si effectivement il y
a une cohérence entre les emplois les
envies ça peut être des emplois salariés
mais aussi des emplois de création
d'entreprises et un dispositif
indestructible de formation et puis
dernier point rapide sur le découpage
voilà c'est à dire on a découpé les
intercos il y a cet atelier que moi
j'appelle des coupages voyez ciseaux
colle bon pourquoi pas en tout cas voilà
aujourd'hui moi je pense qu'il est
extrêmement imprudent d'entreprendre de
quelques réformes que ce soit sans
évaluation
et nous l'avons dit dans le rapport sur
la simplification que nous avons fait
avec Rémi quintro le déficit
d'évaluation qu'on dit parfois à des
aventures un peu hasardeuse et que
l'expérimentation et l'évaluation
devrait vraiment quitter notre ex je ne
serais pas plus longue je regarde mes
collègues qui déborde de questions
madame la Présidente Monsieur est
président dans l'ordre d'inscription
Bernard delco et Charles guene et
ensuite Olivier Pacaud Patricia gillingy
et Dominique Estrosi ça sonne mes chers
collègues bien merci merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de ce moment d'échange et
madame la Présidente pour votre propos
que que je partage complètement j'aurais
envie de rebondir sur beaucoup de sujets
mais évidemment je vais me limiter et
revenir sur les mobilités juste avant
vous dire que je partage complètement
l'orientation que vous proposez sur la
question du droit à construire qui est
un moment de de mettre fin ou de limiter
ou de stopper vous avez dit l'hyper
métropolisation pour garder des marches
de droit à construire dans les
territoires ruraux c'est des questions
des enjeux importants à la fois la
matière d'écologie d'environnement mais
aussi et de codion sociale et
d'apaisement social j'ai envie de dire
sur les mobilités je reviens sur la
question du ferroviaire vous aviez
sollicité un plan de 100 milliards avec
une durée qui est scalée ça ça se
regarde
dans quelques années repris dans les
médias même si ce n'est pas tout à fait
l'annonce la première ministre on a
beaucoup parlé des RER métropolitaires
on a beaucoup parlé de l'urbaine et peu
des petites lignes nous partageons des
lignes que nous connaissons bien pour
lesquelles nous nous battons
le Massif Central est vraiment doté d'un
réseau ferroviaire important qui depuis
des années des années vous l'avez
rappelé ça date pas d'aujourd'hui
a été pénalisé par non seulement pas
d'investissement pas de modernisation
mais aussi pas d'entretien nous avons
une ligne que nous partageons la ligne
de l'Aubrac qui a fermé 11 mois en 2021
faute d'entretien c'est quand même
incroyable et donc ma question est
simple je sais que vous êtes attaché
personnellement à cette ligne en fait
pour vraiment remettre en service ces
lignes et offrir un service tel qu'il
doit être aujourd'hui combien il
faudrait-il investir sur les réseaux des
petites lignes sur le réseau des petites
lignes et dans quel dans quel délai et
comment Céline qui sont parfois
fréquentées parfois peu faute faute
évidemment de service adaptés aux
besoins d'aujourd'hui combien
faudrait-il investir sur ces petites
lignes plutôt dans le secteur rural et
ces territoires qui n'ont pas la chance
de disposer de de grandes
infrastructures ferroviaires combien
faudrait-il vraiment investir pour
remettre ces lignes en état de répondre
aux besoins des usagers mais aussi des
entreprises de ces territoires
oui merci madame la Présidente
madame la Présidente nous avait parlé
à la fois des libertés locales et un peu
de la crise et la nécessité du
changement de modèle
s'il est bien un domaine où on est
obligé de constater de changement de
modèle c'est notamment celui de la
fiscalité et des finances locales et
simplement autrefois la liberté est dans
ce domaine s'appelait autonomie fiscale
force cette constater que maintenant
on partage beaucoup les impôts nationaux
et disons que vous êtes probablement
les chefs de fil dans ce domaine puisque
nous encore le bloc communal est encore
plus à l'aise mais on sent quand même
que c'est une une tendance lourde et
alors comme vous allez
rencontrer le président le 13 mars bien
entendu je pense que vous avez peut-être
à évoqué cet aspect on ne sait jamais
mais bien que vous n'ayez pas l'air de
mal vivre cette mutation
il me semble qu'elle pose de sujets au
moins celui de la gouvernance un peu
parce que
vis-à-vis de l'État comment on
partage-t-on cette ressource et je crois
que je ne sais pas si notre pays est
vraiment équipé pour faire ça il y a des
pays riverains comme comme je regarde
Franck mais par exemple l'Allemagne qui
a l'habitude de partager beaucoup plus
ces choses là et le second aspect c'est
non seulement avec l'État le partage
doit être fait mais entre les régions
aussi comment cela peut-il se passer et
est-ce que vous avez dans ce domaine une
stratégie où on est votre réflexion
est-ce que vous allez poser en disant
peut-être au niveau institutionnel
quelques questions de dans ce domaine au
président de la République
madame la Présidente avec une série de
trois questions parfait
merci beaucoup madame le présidente
d'abord excusez-moi de mon retard je ne
sais pas qui intervenu en premier moi
j'ai eu le plaisir que d'entendre votre
accent chantant et c'est toujours
plaisant pour débuter la journée
je j'ai deux petites questions la
première vous l'avez très brièvement
évoqué la présidente Gatel aussi c'est
la taille des régions suite à cette
rumeur d'éventuelles redécoupage
j'avoue que j'étais très surpris de
cette rumeur même si faut pas se voiler
la face les grandes régions posent
problème
je suis issu d'une région entre
guillemets intermédiaire c'est-à-dire
une région ce sont les hauts de France
j'ai deux de mes collègues Picards nous
étions jadis des Picards donc Laurent de
la Somme Antoine de laine on a de l'Oise
j'étais conseiller régional et ça
fonctionnait très bien la région
Picardie la région Hauts-de-France qui
est plus grande c'est un peu plus
difficile très objectivement alors il
faudra si jamais on redécoupe parce que
le but c'est une efficience de
gouvernance
les régions sont-elles elles-mêmes les
mieux placées pour s'auto-évaluer
évidemment non on peut pas être jugé
parti et je vois mal un exécutif dire
on fonctionne pas bien pour tel ou telle
chose mais je vais vous prendre un
exemple moi qui me semble symbolique de
cette difficulté à fonctionner quand on
est dans des territoires un petit peu
trop grands ce sont les transports
scolaires les transports scolaires bon
Nadine tu voulais peut-être en parler
bon les transports scolaires qui jadis
étaient du département et alors
évidemment ce sont les mêmes services
qui s'en occupent ils ont été transférés
c'est évident sauf que jadis le
vice-président dans mon département qui
était en charge des transports scolaires
ils connaissaient toutes les lignes mais
vraiment au coup de près moi j'étais
vice-prés en charge des collèges
j'allais dans tous mes collègues deux
fois par an et je connaissais tout par
coeur l'actuel vice-président charge de
cette question à la région des
Hauts-de-France
il sait pas où se situe
précis où il est groseilliers etc ce
n'est pas possible et la problématique
c'est que finalement qui prend le
pouvoir ce sont les administratifs il y
a une technocratisation dans ce cas très
précis et la réponse apportée lorsqu'il
y a un problème alors apporter à un
usager à un parent d'élèves à des des
élus
elle est pas forcément la plus adaptée
l'élu va faire l'élu régional en charge
de la question on va faire confiance à
ses services c'est logique mais il
l'aura peut-être pas la bonne réponse je
veux dire il y a un risque de
technocratisation dans ces grandes
régions moi je le ressens vraiment on a
un excellent président de région dans
les Hauts-de-France mais je dis va
convaincu que la cette course au
gigantisme ait été efficace j'ai une
deuxième toute petite question je suis
pas sûr que ça a été abordé mais le
conseiller territorial quid qu'en
pensez-vous
voilà des questions diverses et variées
fort pertinentes en tout cas
je vais je vais vous répondre sur la
question des grandes régions
Franck pourra également complété sur les
questions fiscales
également et puis Franck voilà
développera sur la question du
financement des lignes d'aménagement du
territoire et toi François tu pourras
après compléter ces différents sujets
alors sur
la question du Conseil Territorial les
présidents de région sont
majoritairement contre le conseiller
territorial parce que
les nouvelles
les nouvelles régions donc des grandes
régions cela rend complètement inopérant
la volonté qui avait pu prévaloir sur
le conseil territorial parce que sur
l'Occitanie ça voudrait dire qu'il y
aurait 458
il y a une assemblée à 458 personnes
oui mais oui messieurs là attention vous
pouvez pas
redécouper les cantons vous pouvez la
question si on fait si on veut à son
voilà ça veut dire si on veut avoir de
la proximité enfin je veux dire il faut
savoir que je reviens au début de mon
propos introductif c'est la clarté il
faut savoir quel est l'objectif si
l'objectif c'est la proximité aussi
réduire le nombre lit c'est pas pareil
parce que donc sur la question des
des cantons
j'ai participé au gouvernement valse et
donc j'ai défendu cette réforme et le
canton le plus grand de France en termes
de superficie est en commun j'ai sur mes
terres natale il y a sandy communes
donc je voilà je mesure non mais je
mesure ce que c'est qu'un canton à Sandy
communes voilà l'ancienne député que je
suis d'une circonscription de 290
communes voilà c'est ce que c'est donc
bon aujourd'hui majoritairement les
présidents de région voilà ils sont
opposés
de pour être transparent de
son dans un état d'esprit plutôt ouvert
et prêt à y travailler donc exavi
Bertrand et Christelle Morancez et puis
après pour tout le reste nous y sommes
opposés parce que nous jugeons que cela
n'est pas pertinent alors pour les
présidents de gauche ça a été c'est une
constance mais pour les autres de par
les nouvelles configuration alors sur le
question du fonctionnement des grandes
régions je partage votre analyse que ce
n'est pas au président de nos régions de
faire juste le diagnostic mais ce que
j'ai indiqué c'est que l'INSEE a fait
une évaluation des grandes régions sur
l'aspect du développement économique et
là a démontré la plus-value des grandes
régions pour la structuration des
filières industrielles
donc très clairement parce que là aussi
il faut savoir quels sont les enjeux
voilà quels sont les enjeux et on doit
fixer les enjeux aux régions alors soit
les régions on considère que nous devons
être sur la question de la création
d'emploi de la création de valeur et là
je mets au défi un quelconque expert de
démontrer que les grandes régions ce
n'est pas pertinent
quand vous voulez créer une filière
économique vous devez la créer de bout
en bout et sur quatre départements je
suis désolé ce n'est pas pertinent voilà
ce n'est pas pertinent une filière
économique il faut que vous puissiez en
jeu parce que du terme non comme on est
de Toulouse c'est la Supply Chain la
Supply chaîne il faut la prendre du
début à la fin une filière économique
c'est ça voilà et sur la question des
énergies renouvelables des nouvelles de
la reine industrialisation vous devez
être en capacité d'agir un sur la
formation c'est d'ailleurs les
universités d'agir avec les centres de
recherche et l'innovation de nouveau là
c'est les régions ensuite vous devez
avoir des grands porteurs industriels là
de nouveau c'est les régions qui
puissent travailler vous devez après
travailler sur la structuration de la
sous-traitance vous devez également
travailler sur toutes les
infrastructures en plus de celles de la
formation de l'enseignement supérieur
qui favorise le développement économique
c'est la question des mobilités voilà et
là à ce moment là vous avez une une
pertinence
donc après il faut qu'on ait une
évaluation et nous sommes alors là bien
sûr tout disposer à donner tous les
chiffres de cette démonstration alors
sur la question des transports scolaires
en Occitanie le transport scolaire il
est gratuit
il est gratuit j'ai vu mes dotations UBC
comme tous les présidents de région on
rend la première ministre borne c'est la
première année où nous n'avons pas de
baisse des dotations mais depuis cinq
ans nous avons eu chaque année de baisse
de dotation et
la région Occitanie et la région de
France ont été les deux régions les plus
impactées pour des
sujets qui sont liés mais monsieur le
sénateur de la Haute-Marne s'en rappelle
de la réforme de la TP ou c'est des
avions été les deux régions les voilà
les plus impactés donc on a vu quand
même nous avez Bertrand et moi-même nous
avons une notation mais cette façon
significative si j'ai réussi à faire la
gratuité des transports scolaires sur 13
départements c'est parce que les
économies que j'ai faites sur la gestion
qui était faite par les départements
m'ont permis de faire la gratuité il y a
180 000 enfants tous les jours
qui circulent dans du transport scolaire
et cette question de la connaissance
vous l'avez un mon accent
le commun j'étends des territoires les
moins dense de France j'y suis très
attachée à ce qu'on connaît cela la
réalité de vie de nos concitoyens et je
comprends tout à fait que vous pouvez
penser que une région comme la mienne
pas très départements ne permet pas
d'avoir une bonne connaissance ce n'est
pas vrai quand il y a une volonté
politique on connaît bien je sur les 13
départements j'ai 18 maisons de la
région
c'est-à-dire que j'ai des fonctionnaires
qui sont implantés donc des élus
régionaux qui ont les bureaux aussi qui
sont implantés dans 18 maisons de la
région
et j'ai réussi à faire sur mon premier
mandat 200 millions d'euros d'économies
donc ça veut dire qu'il y a des
solutions parce que je partage la
nécessité parce que le transport
scolaire c'est pas du porte-à-porte mais
quasiment voilà donc
il faut connaître que la route elle est
en pente que dans telle territoire ben
les enfin n'étant pas où elle est à côté
d'un ruisseau et donc ça veut dire que
elle est plus souvent gelée ainsi de
suite voilà tout ça je connais par coeur
je suis une pyrénéenne voilà mais quand
vous voulez connaître le terrain vous
mettez en place un dispositif et vous
pouvez le faire ça s'appelle du
volontarisme politique et sur la
question du transport scolaire c'est
cela la réalité sur 13 départements
voilà j'ai réussi à mettre en place la
gratuité des transports scolaires et
c'est pas parce que j'ai eu des
dotations supplémentaires c'est parce
que et je le dis à mes collègues par
président de département voilà je leur
dis voilà
ça a été mieux géré voilà c'est simple
clair et net et ça si vous préférez sur
la question de lutter contre
l'enfermement
parce que il y a l'éducation ça y
participe sur sur ces sujets là
donc après mais je
ne sommes ouverts sur d'autres
dysfonctionnement qui peuvent être
vécues mais moi je me permets d'insister
sur la question de l'économie
on voit quand même que l'industrie en
France elle est au même niveau que
l'industrie en Grèce
au début mais je suis une ancienne
latiniste helléniste et je suis
passionnée par la Grèce voilà ce pays
j'adore ce pays mais quand on me dit que
mon pays la France a le même niveau
d'industrialisation que la Grèce si on
prévoit je pense quand même quand il y a
un vrai sujet la Grèce a de nombreuses
qualités que j'admire mais d'être ramené
quand même au niveau de l'industrie de
la Grèce si vous préférez c'est pas
quand même ça jamais briller de ce côté
là par la pensée la graisse à briller
mais pas quand même par le système
industriel donc nous avons un enjeu et
si nous continuons à ne pas privilégier
la question de la souveraineté
nous aurons des lendemains qui
descendent voilà donc
moi je il faut savoir quels sont les
objets quels sont les priorités dans ce
pays si nous ne reprenons pas notre
destin en main
si nous ne sommes pas en capacité
d'avoir une souveraineté chacun sait que
quand je dis souveraineté sur certains
même pas de se replier sur soi pour pour
l'ouverture je pour la rencontre je pour
la mondialisation et je considère que
l'autre quel que soit sa couleur de peau
est une chance voilà mais nous devons
avoir une reprise en main et nous devons
en termes économique être très
volontariste voilà et on peut pas
continuer sur la division et si juste
sur l'économie les régions elles ça va
aussi bien aider le boucher qui fait sa
tournée c'est à dire qu'on finance un
centre Val de Loire François il finance
le boucher qui a un camion qui fait la
tournée des villages comme on finance la
le centre de recherche international
d'une entreprise ainsi de suite on sait
le faire il faut avoir de la de la
volonté et puis sur la question des
finances locales les l'ensemble des
présidents de région nous préférerions
que avoir une autonom Ie fiscale qu'une
autonomie financière parce que la
problématique dans ce pays c'est que
l'autonomie financière n'est pas
garantie par la Constitution
contrairement mais ça Franck peut le
défaut le fait encore mieux que moi que
les lendeurs Allemands c'est-à-dire que
nous avons une autonomie financière qui
chaque année est soumise
vote du Parlement et nous avons eu quand
même je le rappelle la désagréable
surprise en 2017 les régions de voir nos
dotations
d'une année à l'autre de baisser quand
même de 500 millions donc l'année 2017
elle a été compliquée pour nos budgets
donc nous préférerions avoir une
autonomie fiscale d'ailleurs c'est le
livre blanc des régions et que nous
avions rédigé pour les candidats à la
présidentielle il y a de son nom nous
l'avions mis ce n'est pas la tendance
actuelle puisque les départements ont
perdu l'autonomie fiscale le bloc
communal en garde un peu mais de façon
certes peut-être philosophique mais
surtout de façon responsable nous
pensons les présidents de région que
quand on dirige on doit être responsable
et la question de l'impôt est une forme
de responsabilité j'ai été maire voilà
je menais une politique fiscale et je
l'assumais donc et quand il faut faire
des augmentations on fait des
augmentations donc moi je pense que même
pour la démocratie locale si vous
préférez il est une bonne chose d'avoir
un impôt local corrélé à aux compétences
parce que il y a ce sujet quand même
aussi sans être trop longue quand les
régions nous investissons massivement
sur l'économie nous en avons aucune
retombe mais ce sont les
intercommunalités qui l'ont
voilà parfois dans les discussions avec
mes 150 présidents de concombre quand
ils me disent oui mais il faut que tu
augmentes encore la subvention pour ça
je fais oui d'accord mais j'ai la
fiscalisé c'est qui qui la reçoit les
amis voilà
Olivier Pacaud
un témoignage une région qui n'a pas
changé de périmètre même si c'est une
grande région puisque en taille malgré
les changements qui se sont faits on
reste dans la moyenne supérieure des
régions la région Centre-Val de Loire et
je veux dire de ce point de vue là
combien je suis d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire Carole delgas sur ce que
sont les régions ce qu'elles apportent
aujourd'hui à la modernisation de notre
pays il est des compétences il est des
compétences qui si elle n'était pas
abordée par les régions sur un
nécessairement portée par l'État dans un
retour à la sonde à la centralisation
nous sommes le rempart contre une
nouvelle centralisation je le dis avec
beaucoup de force
les sujets économiques que tu as évoqué
avec beaucoup de patients ne peuvent pas
si on veut les prendre dans leur
globalité ne peuvent pas être abordés
par des mailles qui seraient des mailles
plus petites ça veut pas dire qu'ils ne
sont pas abordés avec ces mailles plus
petites mais ne peuvent pas être abordés
pourquoi parce que lorsqu'il s'agit de
la recherche et du développement il faut
penser les laboratoires il faut penser
les universités lorsqu'il s'agit des
ressources humaines il faut penser la
mobilité et bien au-delà des com com et
souvent au-delà des départements
lorsqu'il s'agit de la mobilisation
financière importante et c'est sur ce
point là vous y avez fait allusion qu'il
faut créer et renforcer les solidarités
des régulations nationales et interf
régionales il faut véritablement penser
à l'échelle des régions ce qui m'amène à
dire que
sur le conseiller territorial c'est pas
une histoire de défense mais je sais par
expérience il y a quelques années je
préside cette région je sais par
expérience que les bonnes solutions sur
l'économie les bonnes solutions sur
l'enseignement supérieur les bonnes
solutions sur l'aménagement du
territoire en termes de mobilité ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas la somme des
intérêts locaux
et lorsque ce sujet il est abordé par la
somme des interlocaux dans nos
hémicycles et ça arrive j'appelle mes
collègues à travailler avec la vision
qui est la vision globale
en articulant avec les intérêts locaux
ici vous partez de la somme des intérêts
locaux avec le conseiller territorial et
il pourra pas en être autrement il ne
pourra pas en être autrement je le vois
moi session après session à ce moment-là
on perdra la force de l'aménagement du
territoire et soyez assurés qu'elle sera
prise reprise à un autre niveau et ce
sera à nouveau un isolement de la France
dans cette vision hyper centralisée
hyper verticale qui nous a fait tant de
mal parce qu'on ne peut pas régler des
problèmes territoriaux à partir de Paris
et seulement à partir de Paris je veux
insister là-dessus regardons quand même
et je laisserai la parole à Franck
regardons quand même le problème de la
de la mobilité
on a quand même eu le rapport Spinetta
personne oserait le dire aujourd'hui
mais il y a pas très longtemps le
rapport Spinetta je me rappelle j'étais
en session mon cabinet m'apporte un une
déclaration il y avait la liste des
régions des lignes dans ma région qui
allaient fermer alors que nous nous
demandions la réouverture de ligne de
fret nous demandions la modernisation et
la réouverture de ligne de voyageurs et
donc il faut tout faire pour que la
vitalité de nos territoires il a reçu je
crois qu'on est en phase avec vous et
avec l'expression du constante du
président marché la vitalité des
territoires doit être un élément qui
construit qui participe à la
construction de la vision nationale si
nous rompons avec cela et si nous
affaiblissions les régions on serait
dans une situation particulièrement
délétère déposer la question des sommes
si on relie le problème du transport
transport collectif et par la route et
par le rail au problème qui est le
problème central aujourd'hui de la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique on
voit bien qu'il y a là un enjeu
financier considérable qui nous dépasse
et qui nous dépasse tous et qu'il faut
trouver les modèles financiers de
portage de ces investissements sur des
durées moyennes et longues parce que
sans quoi on sera pas au rendez-vous moi
dans ma région j'ai il y a urgence à
réouvrir un certain nombre de lignes
parce que la population s'est agrégée de
manière différente et parce que
aujourd'hui on a des routes qui sont
totalement dangereuses et saturées que
le réflexe ça peut être faire plus de
route mais ce serait complètement
stupide d'aller ainsi c'est pourquoi la
proposition des RER
urbains etc il faut la réfléchir et la
prendre au sérieux mais elle est loin de
tout couvrir réouverture des petites
lignes ouverture de nouvelles lignes
ligne de fret on vient de faire entre
entre deux régions la région Normandie
et la région Centre-Val de Loire une un
accord pour lancer un programme pour le
transport sur le rail de l'équivalent de
170 camions par jour entre Orléans
puisqu'on est au centre de la France et
qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup de d'enjeux de
logistique et Le Havre mais ces sujets
là il faut que nous les à une échelle
bien supérieure je un point sur le zan
quand même un point sur Lausanne je veux
attirer votre attention c'est un combat
que je mène avec l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales et hier
encore Nadine dans le dans l'Indre
puisque j'ai animé une réunion sur
l'économie une réunion avec des
collectivités territoriales je trouve et
je l'ai dit un faux ministre et puis
préfet de région je trouve que le terme
il est particulièrement dangereux parce
que si on pose ça sur le bureau d'un
fonctionnaire de l'État et je le remets
absolument pas en cause ni sa compétence
ni son intégrité mais si on dit que
l'objectif c'est zéro très franchement
des choses bloquées on va en avoir
énormément et moi je suis pour
l'objectif il faut reconstruire le
village sur le village la ville sur la
ville il faut qu'on ait des
constructions verticales en matière
industrielle il y a très beaux exemples
à l'extérieur
inspirons-nous de cela mais ne posons
pas cette histoire il faut qu'il y ait
une intelligence du projet de chaque
projet qui soit mesuré par les
l'autorité de l'État qui a un avis à
donner mais ne posons pas un cadre même
si l'objectif est bon attention à ce
cadre on peut pas dire ça et en même
temps on dit rien industrialisation
pousser nos industriels aller rapatrier
des productions qui sont en Asie
aujourd'hui et pour leur dire notre
horizon c'est zéro
juste un mot si vous permettez pour
terminer peut-être sur le conseiller
territorial il faut souvenir que l'idée
elle a 15 ans il y a 15 ans un
conseiller départemental un conseiller
régional
co-financer les mêmes les équipements
c'est-à-dire qu'on avait partout des
financements croisés on parle plus des
financements croisés aujourd'hui ou
quasiment plus aujourd'hui quand on fait
de l'économie dans les régions et les
seuls à faire de l'économie quand on
fait les transports on est les seuls à
faire du transport les départements font
autre chose ils sont l'univers social
qui est un défi énorme donc à l'époque
l'idée c'était de se dire puisque tout
le monde finance la même chose et qu'on
veut moins d'élus faisons le conseil
territorial sur le papier c'était
séduisant et ça pouvait être entendu par
la population donc moins d'élus mais
demain moins d'élus ça veut dire moins
de proximité avec les territoires
et les territoires étang gigantesques ça
veut dire un conseiller alors que je
sais pas comment on l'appellera
territorial qui aura peut-être 250
communes à gérer il y arrivera pas donc
on aura une perte de proximité et je
sais que le Sénat est toujours sensible
à cette question la proximité et puis
deuxièmement c'est le métier de
Conseiller régional le métier entre
guillemets de conseil régional
aujourd'hui est très différente celui
d'un conseiller départemental alors qu'à
l'époque étant donné qu'on financer tous
et qu'on apparaissait tous dans le
fameux millefeuille voilà la loi notre
et la loi Matam sont échangés
complètement l'action des régions d'un
côté l'action des départements de
l'autre donc pour moi il y a plus le
sujet
un mot effectivement pour répondre aux
questions du sénateur de cross sur le
les petites lignes je suis pas sûr qu'un
recensement été fait au niveau national
dans cette petite ligne sont importantes
on parle on parle de capillaire
c'est tout dire de capillaire voyageur
de capillaire fret je vais vous citer un
exemple pour mon seul département et sur
la seule question du capillaire fret
pour desservir des coopératives
agricoles
betteravières etc
il y a même pas un an SNCF
on dit réseau nous indique 5 mois avant
voilà on va fermer les lignes 5 mois
avant il y a ça veut dire qu'on basculé
environ
12 à 15000 camions en lieu et place des
trains qui passent à tous les jours mais
régulièrement
sur un seul département celui de la
Marne 44 millions pour deux lignes de
fret donc vous imaginez à l'échelle
nationale contenue du réseau qu'on a sur
lequel on a parfois pas investi depuis
plus de 100 ans l'état du ballast
le nombre de passages à niveau
l'état de l'infrastructure des rails qui
ont plus de 100 ans qui avec le
réchauffement climatique entraîne
aujourd'hui des déraillements donc la
somme elle est en dizaines de dizaines
de milliards pour le seul réseau
capillaire et je pense que l'exercice
n'a jamais été fait au niveau national
tant les sommes sont effrayantes moi je
pense que l'avenir de ces petites lignes
c'est probablement un autre modèle de
train plus léger
avec un changement de référentiel la
SNCF il se trouve que j'ai visité dans
ma région il y a peu de temps mais je
sais qu'il y a d'autres expériences dans
d'autres régions un train beaucoup plus
petit beaucoup plus léger qui a une
empreinte carbone au kilomètre inférieur
de 90% par rapport au train actuel parce
qu'il fonctionne sur des batteries
électriques
et que les coûts d'exploitation sont
divisés par 5 par rapport au référentiel
actuel de la SNCF je pense que l'avenir
de ces petites lignes il faut les
préserver parce que je suis intimement
persuadé que si on fait le choix de ce
que Carole expliquait tout à l'heure qui
est de redevenir des grands spécialistes
du transport mais aussi bien des TGV que
du transport de pitling il faut qu'on
invente ces trains de demain il
fonctionne en Alsace sur une ou deux
lignes expérimentale dans un an dans un
an et demi exactement ce train circulera
il s'appelle le drésy il s'appelle
draisy on va le faire fonctionner
pendant un an sans passager simplement
pour voir s'il fonctionne mais par
exemple je vous donne l'exemple de ce
type de train il est avec un
pilote à bord il peut devenir autonome
un jour l'autre mais quand on arrive
près d'un passage à niveau il a la
capacité de ralentir pour laisser passer
les voitures ou passer etc c'est à dire
qu'on n'a pas à refaire tous les
passages à niveau ce qui engendre des
coûts sur ces petites lignes qui sont
insurmontables pour aucune collectivité
et pour l'État donc l'avenir de ces
petites lignes il faut le penser
autrement je pense que si on veut
j'allais dire donner des signes forts à
la ruralité il faut inventer un autre
type de train nos industriels sont
capables de le faire aujourd'hui ils
travaillent aujourd'hui et je pense
qu'on aura besoin pour le coup de
régions fortes pour investir au côté de
l'État sur cette problématique des
transports
sur le zan je vais prendre encore
l'exemple de l'Alsace on a une sénatrice
de l'Alsace qui est présente ici un
département comme l'Alsace un
département très dense
ce département ne pourra jamais arriver
aux ânes pourquoi parce que son
développement est-elle qu'il n'arrivera
pas à compenser
l'urbanisation qu'il connaîtra ou qu'il
subira quand on est à proximité du SUNGO
du côté de Saint-Louis vous êtes en
bordure de la frontière suisse quand
vous êtes à l'heure en métropole de
Strasbourg ou ailleurs vous connaissez
un développement économique extrêmement
important qui va falloir compenser à
l'échelle
a supposer que la région Alsace
redevienne région
à l'échelle d'une région Alsace l'Alsace
est incapable de compenser l'arrivée aux
âmes si elle ne va pas compenser sur une
autre partie de la région où on a
parfois des dizaines de milliers
d'hectares de friches qui pourraient
retrouver vie ou être renaturé dans
l'équilibre du Zam et ça on a quand même
dans notre pays entre 180 000 et 200 000
hectares de friches c'est considérable
c'est bien plus que ce que nous
artificialisons en globalité le problème
c'est que il faut aller les chercher
elles sont pas forcément à l'endroit
où on voudrait faire du développement
économique parce que c'est friche elles
sont liées à une crise industrielle qui
a vécu et si on a mis à une époque dans
certaines vallées des usines on les
mettrait plus dans ces mêmes vallées
aujourd'hui donc il faut avoir des
régions suffisamment grandes pour que
cette organisation du zan se fasse et je
rejoins évidemment totalement ce qu'a
dit François tout à l'heure sur sur la
maladresse de ce de ce terme qui fait
peur à tout le monde moi je suis en plus
président des maires de la Marne puisque
je suis encore présent de
l'agglomération
c'est la question numéro 1 dans toutes
nos assemblées parce que ce terme a fait
peur à tout le monde et tout le monde
imaginait que le développement enfin
Lausanne c'était demain matin la réforme
n'a pas été expliquée les
décrets d'application n'ont pas
correspondu à l'esprit de la commission
mixte permanente c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire et puis on mêlait les projets
d'État une centrale nucléaire avec un
petit lotissement ou une petite zone
artisanale donc on mettait tout dans le
même dans le même sac et demain
l'installation par l'état d'un centre de
retraitement de déchets nucléaires comme
on chez nous j'allais dire impacter
l'enveloppe régionale de manière
considérable et on avait le sentiment
d'être lésé et puis tous les territoires
ruraux avaient le sentiment que une fois
de plus je reprends leur expression
entre guillemets c'était les territoires
métropolitains qui allaient absorber
toute la capacité d'urbanisation au
détriment des honorales donc l'idée on
ne peut que qui souscrire parce
qu'effectivement les sols ont un rôle
extrêmement important dans la
séquestration du carbone et si on veut
arriver en 2050 à la neutralité carbone
il faut aller aux ânes mais la méthode a
été
désastreuse et il est temps de la
corriger si on veut entraîner les élus
dans cet objectif mais effectivement on
sait reconstruire la vie sur la ville on
sait redensifier les coeurs de village
on sait j'ai vu notre jour j'étais
dernier exemple que je cite en Lorraine
dans l'usine qui fabrique les masters de
Renault
c'est une ligne qui se trouve à bâtir le
chef d'entreprise le chef du site
responsable du site a réussi à récupérer
trois hectares sur 16 hectares
construits en réorganisant son stockage
en entreprise il me dit avec ça je vais
rapatrier des sous-traitants dans mon
entreprise alors qu'avant il y avait les
transports etc mais je me suis rendu
compte qu'avant stocké à l'horizontale
maintenant c'est stocké la verticale
quand on doit chauffer 16 hectares au
lieu de 13 c'est pas la même chose donc
il me dit moi l'enjeu énergétique j'ai
dit à mes équipes regardez on peut
gagner de la place et je dégage trois
hectares dans mon entreprise donc ça
aussi c'est du zen
combien d'entreprises ont acheté dans
les années 70 hectares et n'en occupe
que 5 aujourd'hui parce qu'on stocke on
stocke des palettes on sait les trucs
comme ça donc ces espaces ils existent
aujourd'hui et je pense que les ânes il
est aujourd'hui compliqué parce que le
projet était mal vendu il a pas été
vendu du tout d'ailleurs puisque en plus
on arrivait en période électorale il a
pas été ça c'est clair ça c'est clair et
donc l'idée elle est louable mais il
faut reprendre la méthode il faut
reprendre la méthode en lien avec les
territoires parce que sinon on risque
d'avoir un rejet ce qui serait une
catastrophe pour l'écologie
juste sur ce sujet du
juste sur ce sujet du zan il faut le
mettre en corrélation avec la question
des établissements publics fonciers
parce que là j'ai pu constater un
devenant présidente de région de France
que la relation avec les établissements
publics fonciers et très différentes
d'une région à l'autre
parce que
nous avons un Occitanie une très très
bonne relation avec l'établissement
public fonciers et donc c'est clairement
un bras armé de la région pour la
question de la reconquête des friches
industrielles
voilà des friches tout court vous savez
sur les îlots dans certaines villes qui
sont laissées à l'abandon ainsi de suite
mais cela voyez je me suis rendu compte
en discutant et en allant sur d'autres
régions de France que c'est très
variable d'une région à l'autre et ça
c'est très dommageable parce que quand
vous avez une vraie politique du foncier
mené par la région avec le PF il y a une
vraie efficacité une vraie efficacité
pour la question des friches ça c'est
vraiment sur les friches commerciales
sur les friches artisanales sur même le
conseil comme tu l'indiqué que l'on peut
mener parce que quand vous avez des
agences régionales de l'aménagement et
de la construction comme j'ai un
Occitanie moi mon agence régionale
travaille fortement avec le PF parce que
à la fois on permet l'achat de friche et
en même temps on donne le conseil pour
la reconfiguration voilà mais cela en
fait je me suis rendu compte que c'était
un écosystème qui était favorable parce
que les personnes se connaissent bien
ainsi de suite dans d'autres régions
quand il n'y a pas cette coopération il
y a une perdition d'efficacité qui est
terrible et pour aider
justement à la réussite du Zéro
artificialisation nette qu'il y ait
vraiment une
une prise vraiment emmène des EPF par
les régions ça permettrait d'avoir une
très grande efficacité vraiment
juste pour clan sur le zan alors je vous
encourage à soutenir la proposition de
loi du Sénat qui remet on va dire un peu
de
d'intelligence territoriale et surtout
d'efficacité et que cette proposition de
loi n'intègre pas les deux éléments que
vous avez évoqués qui sont importants le
financement par le biais des EPS et
l'ingénierie qui est nécessaire pour
permettre aux collectivités de définir
un projet intelligent ça nous n'avons
pas pu le mettre dans la première
proposition parce qu'il y avait urgent à
permettre de redonner du possible et du
faisable sur sur un texte qui a été on
va dire
interpréter d'une manière on va dire
excessive pour être très aimable le voir
détourner de l'esprit du législateur je
serai pas plus parce que on a voilà
cette rencontre nous passionne on a
trois demandes d'intervention il nous
reste 10 minutes je crois donc Patricia
chinangé Dominique escrossi ça sonne et
Antoine Lefebvre qui sont des maîtres en
matière
de de contraction de d'intervention
merci à merci beaucoup
oui d'Alsace bonjour Monsieur Franck le
roi félicitations aussi pour votre
élection qui est voilà c'est on sait pas
encore rencontré mais je me permets de
je suis là alors donc je me permets vous
avez évoqué justement la mobilité et
puis surtout les travaux au niveau
ferroviaire et c'est vrai que on a
cette lenteur est presque
insupportable parce qu'on sait que des
millions ont été déjà mis en place mais
on voit pas les investissements de faits
sur sur des régions comme l'Alsace
puisqu'on sait qu'il y a plus de 750
millions qui devraient être investis sur
les sur les petites lignes et on y a des
attentes sur des lignes comme Colmar
Fribourg au bolv et c'est vrai que on
aimerait bien que il est plus de
d'engagement vers la mobilité et on en a
besoin vous avez rappelé que l'Alsace
est un petit départ deux petits
départements qui sont très denses et où
les transports vraiment pèsent sur les
citoyens et donc effectivement comment
travailler mieux en niveau général au
niveau national de tous ces
investissements avoir au moins des
projets sur 20 ou 15 ans mais que ces
projets soient réalisés et pas à chaque
fois une mandature on dit oui oui ce
sera fait puis le mandat d'après ce sera
toujours pas fait l'harmonisation je
vais revenir aussi sur l'harmonisation
des taxes poids lourds vous savez que
depuis le premier
juillet 2000 l'année dernière
les routes nationales allemandes sont
les poids lourds sont taxés et ils vont
avoir un gain de plus de 2 milliards
d'euros comment aussi travailler avec
toutes les régions en ayant une
harmonisation je crois qu'aujourd'hui
les régions elles font plein de choses
mais elles font souvent des choses aussi
seules et on voit pas cette
harmonisation qui est importante au
niveau des transports mais il y a
d'autres je pourrais évoquer plusieurs
sujets mais il est important de trouver
vraiment ce travail d'efficacité au
niveau national mais au-delà de ça
européen je sais qu'en Alsace il y a une
taxe poids lourd qui va être prévue mais
c'est vrai que sa chagrine un peu que ce
soit que une petite
que deux départements la CEA travail
dessus il faudrait vraiment aujourd'hui
on bouge beaucoup donc voilà ma question
d'harmonisation
en train de ainsi chers Dominique
Estrosi ça nous partons vers le sud
merci Françoise madame la Présidente
Messieurs les Présidents moi je voudrais
vous interroger sur la question de la
décentralisation et de la
déconcentration des politiques du
logement et de l'habitat alors certes ça
relève pas directement de vos
compétences puisque c'est compétences
elles sont plus aux intercommunalités
voire au département mais les régions
sont en la compétence de l'aménagement
du territoire et donc je pense que c'est
important aussi de relier ces politiques
vous savez que la loi 3DS a créé des
autorités organisatrices de l'habitat
qui vise à permettre justement à donner
aux collectivités la capacité locale
d'ajustement des différentes dispositifs
concernant le logement dans leur
territoire aujourd'hui comment est-ce
que vous envisageriez ce contenu de ces
aouaches au travers des dispositifs
justement en lien avec des politiques du
logement et on a besoin aussi que demain
si ces autorités organisatrices de
l'habitat puissent véritablement jouer
leur rôle
puissent bénéficier de financement dédié
ce qui n'est aujourd'hui pas le cas et
on réfléchit fortement à l'instar des
autorités organisatrices de transport
est-ce que là-dessus vous avez des
informations et des jugements à pouvoir
m'apporter s'il vous plaît
dernière question pour l'aine Antoine le
fond dans le Nord mais frontalier de du
Grand Est de la Belgique
en fait madame le Président j'ai
beaucoup de questions étaient évoquées
moi je voulais simplement faire un
commentaire et remercier Franck le roi
justement sur son éclairage par rapport
à la question que j'avais sur le conseil
territorial je pense qu'il y a des
choses à
creuser dans ce qui nous a partagé comme
comme expérience avec notamment cette
prise en compte des des compétences
dédiées on n'est plus en compétence
partagée donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on
en tienne compte si on veut garder
justement cette notion de proximité qui
nous est chère ici au Sénat et puis
aussi mais ça je pense qu'on est on est
bien en phase avec région de France
madame la Présidente sur la position
équilibrée que vous avez exprimé par
rapport aux
ânes plusieurs exemples ont été donnés
donc je vais pas être plus long moi
j'avais simplement madame la Présidente
vous avez évoqué
des solutions sur la fin des concessions
autoroutières est-ce que vous pouvez
rapidement préciser un peu ce que vous
entrevoyez dans ce domaine parce que je
pense qu'il y a il y a aussi quelques
gisements de ce côté merci
les réponses
répondre
[Musique]
c'est toi Françoise qui me mais oui mais
voilà c'est
tout arrive mais tu vas pas commencer à
être dictatrice maintenant
[Rires]
donc sur les autorités organisatrices de
l'habitat nous n'avons pas voilà
d'informations
assez récentes nous sommes
majoritairement les présidents de région
plutôt favorables à le sur la politique
du logement
pour le niveau intercommunal pour
pouvoir avoir une vraie réactivité là il
faut parce que certaines de vos
collègues au Sénat envisagés que ce soit
plutôt les régions et je leur ai indiqué
que nous ne semblait pas pertinents sur
ce sujet où il y a quand même de grands
besoins vraiment donc mais l'habitat
c'est encore différent du logement et
nous n'avons pas
d'informations sur ce sujet mais en
effet si on veut qu'il y ait un vrai
travail sur le logement sur les tous les
aménités tous les services qui sont
amenés à au tour et qui constituent donc
l'habitat il faut à ce moment-là qui si
on doit avoir une coordination qui est
en financement et sur ce sujet de façon
récente nous n'avons aucune indication
donc
Philippe je ne pense pas
oui mais juste voilà c'est vrai que nous
sur ce sujet là ce qu'on a fait remonter
au ministère c'est que vraiment on était
attachés à ce qui est une évolution sur
la gouvernance des EPF et que ça puisse
être vraiment j'aime le terme des bras
armés de la région parce que quand il y
a on va dire une dissonance entre la
région et les EPF c'est c'est terrible
sur la perte de d'efficacité voilà donc
vraiment
oui sur le mais c'est vrai que sur la
question de l'autorité organisatrice de
l'habitat permettrait également d'avoir
une liaison sur l'habitat des jeunes
comme le souffle François également sur
le logement des saisonniers ça c'est
voilà c'est un sujet aussi que nous
avons mais nous récemment nous n'avons
pas été consultés sur les réflexions qui
sont qui sont portés
et sur les concessions autoroutières
donc nous avons la fin des concessions
autoroutières c'est quand même une main
financière substantielle c'est 3
milliards par an et je pense que on doit
revoir complètement ces contrats et
qu'il y ait une réorientation de crédit
pour les mobilités propres
quand j'indique cela bien sûr il y a le
ferviaire mais pas uniquement parce que
moi j'ai beaucoup développé le
ferroviaire mais les régions mènent
aussi des politiques d'aide pour l'achat
de véhicules individuels propres parce
que nous développons le rail quand c'est
possible il y a certaines territoires où
la voiture est la seule et la seule
solution et donc là il est nécessaire
également d'avoir des efforts qui soient
significatifs pour permettre à des
personnes de milieu modeste d'acheter
des véhicules électriques qui sont quand
même objectivement encore d'un coup
élevé voilà je complète juste d'un mot
sur le les péages
CPH s'arrête vers 2031 2032 et leur
niveau va s'effondrer parce qu'en fait
étant donné que ils amortissaient des
travaux de nouvelle autoroutes créées et
qui a plus d'autoroute créée si on
l'obligation que nous avons c'est
normalement de faire fondre le niveau
des sondages des des péages juste pour
l'entretien des autoroutes or nous
considérons que ce serait une erreur que
de baisser le niveau des sondage autant
utiliser cette différence pour investir
dans les infrastructures parce que là
pour le coup ça coûtera pas un centime
de plus au
usagers de l'autoroute mais pour le coup
c'est une manne considérable qui
pourrait être utilisée ou vers des
mobilités négatives comme l'évoque
Carole instant ou tout simplement pour
entretenir les lignes ferroviaires etc
enfin voilà il faut pour ça qu'il faut
penser le transport dans sa globalité
parce que parfois c'est un produit de
transport routier qui va servir à
financer la rail et quand on est dans
une logique de diminution de l'empreinte
carbone il va de soi qu'on a intérêt à
favoriser le rail je réponds très
rapidement à
la scène triste Patricia
l'investissement en Alsace sur les
infrastructures depuis que la région
Grand Est existe par rapport à l'Alsace
sur un exercice complet des deux côtés
c'est 74% de plus et pourtant on est
loin du compte c'est-à-dire que le
besoin en termes de financement de
ferroviaire mais il est gigantesque
c'est pour ça que les 100 milliards
annoncés sont très en dessous du besoin
réel c'est un effort qu'on a noté parce
que effectivement
ça change de la dimension de
l'investissement d'État mais on est
encore très en dessous de ce qu'il
faudrait faire l'Italie met 180
milliards d'euros sur la table
donc on est encore présent en dessous
donc là on a augmenté nous notre
financement sur la seule Alsace de 74%
et pour la petite pour la petite
histoire si vous me permettez on était
l'Alsace s'était mis en difficulté
financièrement quand lorsqu'elle
existait parce qu'elle avait financer
ses trains et l'Alsace a toujours été
assez exemplaire en matière ferroviaire
par du crédit-bail etc qui faisait que
c'était la deuxième région la plus
endettée de France à cause de du portage
du ferroviaire aujourd'hui nous sommes
le grand est la deuxième région la moins
endettée de France parce que notre
surface financière nous a permis de
supporter des investissements qui ont
profité à l'Alsace nos autres
territoires également et et ça ça change
tout donc ça revient un petit peu au
sujet des grandes régions c'est que les
grandes régions une influence quand on
discute je représente une région depuis
quelques semaines qui pèse 5 millions et
demi d'habitants le président de la SNCF
me regarde autrement que si je faisais
un million d'habitants ou un million et
demi d'habitants
le rapport de force a changé aujourd'hui
il est obligé de faire avec le président
de région avant on était enfin il nos
présidents de région précédente était
souvent considérés comme quantité
négligeable parce qu'il faisait pas
grand chose face à la SNCF et la SNCF
est quand même un état dans l'état vous
le savez tous
mais c'est de l'ordre c'est de l'ordre
de 3 milliards d'euros par an
vous avez interpellé dans vos travaux
par une réforme qui est celle de France
travail absolument on mène on mène ce
dossier avec avec Carole avec beaucoup
beaucoup de patients pour faire en sorte
que au détour de cette loi nous n'ayons
pas une reverticalisation
et nous n'ayons pas de confusion entre
l'autorité qui organise en la matière
qui doit être une autorité politique et
l'autorité qui exécute on ne veut pas
d'infrance travail qui serait demain à
la fois la structure qui dit ce qui doit
être et qui a la prétention de faire
soyez attentif à ça les régions marquées
beaucoup de points sur le secteur de la
formation professionnelle on doit rester
vraiment en visibilité et le deuxième
point le sujet de la santé Carole l'a
évoqué rapidement nous sommes preneurs
de discussion à tous les niveaux pour
prendre notre part pour prendre notre
part on sait aujourd'hui la difficulté
du sujet il est absolument
incontournable on va vers une
catastrophe entre l'augmentation du
besoin avec le vieillissement et la
chute des effectifs de médecins il faut
des réformes il faut de la formation on
est preneur pour être plus encore
considéré dans les réflexions qui vont
accoucher nous l'espérons de solutions
urgentes merci monsieur le Président
pour ces deux messages complémentaires
que nous n'avons pas eu le temps de
traiter mais vous savez qu'ils sont nous
partageons la même préoccupation et la
même vision avec le Sénat et c'est très
important que ici on puisse entre
guillemets contaminer les esprits sur ce
que vous disiez autour de France travail
parce que c'est un vrai un vrai sujet et
un sujet de cohérence c'est-à-dire
comment on fabrique l'efficacité de
l'action publique il faut qu'on sorte de
nos silos et de cette vision centralisée
alors je suis vraiment navré de devoir
conclure parce que nous avons un autre
intervenant je voulais vous dire
vraiment l'intérêt qui a été le nôtre de
vous entendre et d'échanger la
conversation que nous devons poursuivre
sur des thèmes qui sont au cœur de la
vie du territoire et brièvement je
voudrais vous dire alors c'est mon ma
conviction personnelle mais je ne doute
pas qu'ici elle soit partagée parce que
nous sommes la chambre des territoires
et qu'ici nous sommes tous
encore des élus locaux et avons été
membres
d'exécutive nous portons mais vraiment
Chevilly au corps la conviction que
c'est la vitalité des territoires qui va
faire le dynamisme de la France ça
n'enlève rien à l'exigence d'un État
fort régalien naturellement ne nous
méprenons pas et que sincèrement moi je
suis convaincu que les régions sont
aujourd'hui des acteurs majeurs du
dynamisme et de la renaissance
économique de nos territoires et partout
ce qui veut dire que c'est ainsi qu'on
désenclavera parce que vous avez une
taille moi je suis de Bretagne nous
sommes à 4 mais nous sommes pas mal
madame la Présidente voilà vous savez
bien bon voilà
bon et que moi je suis toujours sur les
tailles je pense pas que l'efficacité
vient de la taille mais que changer tout
le temps ça bref je vais revenir sur mon
propos
je pense que la force que vous avez
c'est votre capacité d'agir mais surtout
le fait que vous êtes des gens de
conviction on l'a vu et que vous êtes
attachés à vos territoires et que vous
avez la capacité unique mais c'est bien
ça le levier du développement une
capacité unique à fédérer tous les
acteurs au lieu de décider depuis Paris
que dans tel endroit ça et qu'on sait
que la réussite elle vient de cette
capacité à fédérer et à emmener donc
vraiment mille merci de cet échange
remarquable et passionnant que je
souhaite que nous continuons à
entretenir nous sommes vraiment preneurs
de vos contributions que nous lisons
merci vraiment et puis nous comptons sur
vous
merci Madame présidente merci mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs merci
chers amis nous attendons quelqu'un qui
va nous aider à réfléchir martial
Foucault qui est déjà là et nous allons
parler du blues des mers mais le blues
des mers est un type qui doit pas nous
affoler parce que c'est plein
d'espérance aussi voilà